[Music]
it has not been that long since netflix
officially revealed the production of a
series based on the popular video game
horizon zero dawn as can be taken from
the website of the canadian film union
directors guild of canada the netflix
series bears the official title horizon
2074 and will be shot in toronto also
featured on the site are the first crew
members including jack boehm who
previously assisted with the direction
of the boys and michelle brady who is
the creative director for the amazon
series the expanse moreover journalist
and insider jeff grubb revealed in his
podcast that horizon 2074 will not
recount the events of the two video
games rather it will follow the plot
after part two also there will be two
timelines one illustrating the story of
the main character aloy and the other
the downfall of human civilization a loy
story and the end of the world are
separated by about a thousand years that
leaves a lot of potential for an
extensive story that has not been told
in neither of the games yet still it's
questionable why exactly the year 2074
shall be the focus after all mankind was
already wiped out in the 2060s we hope
to have official news about horizon 2074
soon the release date has not been
confirmed for netflix yet
the release of indiana jones 5 is still
about a year away nevertheless the
farewell of two hollywood legends is
already approaching one is film composer
john williams who hinted at his
retirement in an interview with ap he
revealed he was currently working on
indiana jones 5 and would most likely
turn his back on composing for films
afterwards this means that one of the
biggest hollywood artists will be
leaving as the 90 year old john williams
has composed the soundtracks of
countless global hits these include the
well-known indiana jones films star wars
jurassic park harry potter and many
others however it seems that williams
does not want to stop working all
together he has already announced his
intention to keep on writing concert
music the other person to give up his
work is harrison ford who will reach the
age of 80 on july 13th officially he has
not declared the end of his career but
considering his age four's retirement is
certainly imminent as well his partner's
han solo has already been dropped and
there probably won't be another indiana
jones movie with him either the
foundation of more relaxing years would
thus be laid though we are still waiting
for an announcement from ford himself
indiana jones 5 is expected to be
released in theaters on june 30th 2023
in late may the obi-wan kenobi series
was released with great success on
disney plus star wars fans in particular
who enjoyed episodes 1-3 are likely to
find the series very appealing now some
fans are completely satisfied with this
one season and do not want the storyline
to be dragged on others however are
quite fond of the idea of a second
season lead actor ewan mcgregor also
appears to belong to the second group
even before the season finale he told
the british gq magazine in an interview
that he would be very happy if the
series were continued darth vader actor
hayden christensen shares the same
opinion as he would also be up for a
second season however he did confess in
an interview with radio times that the
series was originally intended to be a
standalone the crew of the series seems
to have a different opinion director
deborah chao for instance spoke to
entertainment tonight about the series
being complete and that there were no
plans to go further lucasfilm president
kathleen kennedy supports this view even
though she does not rule out the
possibility of carrying on with the
series if there were a very good reason
to do so thus the responsible parties
behind the camera do not look as
inspired as the main actors but the real
question is what would be the content of
such a second season how should obi-wan
develop further and which stories would
there be to tell about him the people in
charge should come up with a good answer
to all these questions a compromise
solution would be a spin-off about the
inquisitor riva who is played by moses
ingram rumor has it that this is already
in the works but an official
confirmation is still pending in any
case we are looking forward to seeing
how obi-wan's story will evolve and will
continue to keep you up to date
it was only recently that we reported on
the upcoming deadpool 3 and the
statements made by the two screenwriters
rhett reese and paul wernick they
expressed confidence regarding the third
installment even though not every single
joke may be approved by disney now the
two authors had a chance to talk in the
post-credit podcast where besides other
things the sony flop morbius was
mentioned based on what they said reece
and wernick haven't seen the movie at
all but given the amount of memes they
won't be able to avoid including a
morbius gag here and there they likewise
clarified that deadpool would also be an
integral part of the mcu in the future
although they remain silent on the exact
plans to bring it all together reece
also spoke of a so-called fish out of
water comedy in the case of deadpool 3.
this is a metaphor that in the world of
movies means that the protagonist is
plunged into a completely foreign world
a classic example of this would be a
typical country dweller who is suddenly
exposed to the big city life in the case
of deadpool we are talking more about a
crazy anti-hero who has to survive in a
world full of superheroes the union of
deadpool and the mcu certainly holds
some potential a first preview is
already provided by a video from disney
released in the summer of 2021 which
shows the mercenary together with korg
as they watch and comment on free guy in
typical youtube reaction manner it is
unfortunately not known yet when
deadpool 3 will hit theaters but a
release prior to the end of 2023 is
considered highly unlikely
there is hardly any action film series
that enjoys such a cult status as james
bond the british spy who was created by
author ian fleming in as early as 1953
has been part of movie history since
1962. now ever since no time to die it
has been made clear that daniel craig
will no longer be taking on the role of
the double o agent producer barbara
brockley disclosed the current status of
the now 26th bond film in an interview
with deadline according to her the
filming of a new movie alone would take
place in two years at the earliest which
is nothing particularly unusual for the
film series since there is still plenty
of time before shooting begins they have
not even started to look for a successor
to craig just yet as it is many signs
suggest a reimagining of the james bond
character and a new approach in the
upcoming film indeed many fans hope that
the cult figure will not fall victim to
a total makeover for instance no time to
die already toyed with the idea that at
least the agent number 007 will be
filled by lashana lynch in the future
who in some form can also be given a
spin-off film what direction do you
think the bond franchise will continue
to evolve in and what are your
expectations for the 26th bond film feel
free to let us know in the comments
sony pictures achieved significant
success among both critics and fans last
year with ghostbusters afterlife the new
installment impressed especially those
who already like the original from 1984.
now a sequel seems to be in the works
which might be released in the near
future as the official ghostbusters
twitter channel confirmed they plan to
release the sequel already in december
2023. this is ambitious after all the
competition before christmas is
traditionally quite high the new star
trek movie will also be released during
this time for example like already
hinted upon at the end of the first part
the movie is set in manhattan and the
old familiar firehouse from the initial
ghostbusters director jason reitman who
by the way is the son of the original
director ivan reitman already shared
some details regarding the sequel with
the hollywood reporter accordingly the
sequel will follow the end of
ghostbusters afterlife which the ecto-1
enters manhattan and thus returns to its
home meanwhile work is also in progress
on an animated ghostbusters movie which
will be directed by hotel transylvania 4
film director jennifer kluska and motor
city creator chris prynoski jason
reitman also joins the netflix exclusive
series as an executive producer sadly
the series plot as well as the release
date are still unknown
those were the news for this week if you
haven't had enough yet check out our
latest original video on mission
impossible 7 to find out everything
there is to know about the new part of
the action series starring tom cruise
[Music]